the quarterback of the dallas cowboys
dak prescott good to see you jack you as
well thank you for having me now i
appreciate you being here um and uh i i
i normally make it all about my guest
but the guy to your right behind you my
guy tj jefferson is a die-hard cowboys
fan
and die-hard sixer fan so troy aikman's
already been here
james hardest james harden has been
acquired
now you're here um
if the good lord were to call me home
today i'd be like you know what lord i
think i've done it all right
he took me on a good day to call me home
yeah this is it this is my man right
here man you know jack i don't want to
take over this interview but you know
you know
i said it's supposed to be about the
guest but it's always about the host you
know you know as a cowboys fan i take a
lot of heat just because we're the
cowboys i say like i'm on the team with
you and you know it feels good to have
you here and it just justifies all the
heat and all the the arrows that i throw
back because cowboy's nation man we're
in the philippines yeah i appreciate you
uh you know holding it down for us so
it's like i tried to do it i tried to do
it now you've never met die hard cowboy
fans before in your life
have you ever met anybody who puts a
velvet rope in between two golf bags in
front of him because anybody who doesn't
have as many wins as the cowboys all
time or even this year
cannot get past the velvet road no no
it's like to talk to him it's like a guy
like that
the thing is you know so many people
want to talk trash and i'm like all
right i have to have a system right they
got to have credibility who because i
can't fight with everybody
so like i find out who's your team oh if
you have x amount of super bowls there
it is i'll put you in there
you're in the club here's the screen i'm
saying we're sipping on some hennessy or
something
you know if you've been in one or two
super bowls you make the club but you're
not in vip wait so if you have zero wins
in the super bowl wait in line so
bengals fans they're in the super bowl
this year but they must wait in line we
got to talk to him this week yeah and if
you've never made the super bowl please
don't try to talk trash about the
five-time super bowl what do you make of
this deck prescott i like it i like it
yeah i mean you've got to have you've
got to have some kind of standard of
as you said if who can talk to you of
who who do you actually
listen to on their trash talk you know
what i mean they can't argue with
anybody so
anyone can talk right but it's like who
am i going to use my energy to fight
back with anyone can say whatever they
want but who the weakness is valuing
their opinion man that gets it man i
knew he'd get it rich i knew he could i
know you know and michael irvin adored
this system yeah of course honestly
he's thinking where can i get that rope
for nfl network he's like taking it with
him but at any rate that's tj jefferson
here on the rich eisen show dak prescott
is here 844 204 rich number to dial
we're here on the rich eyes and show
terrestrial radio network and joining us
here in person is none other than the
quarterback of the dallas cowboys
courtesy of sleep number dak prescott
what's up what's up yeah great to see
you once you get into town when you got
in yesterday okay i got in yesterday uh
dinner with the group um and then here
today start to start the day off i will
go nationwide and now uh the best part
okay very good i
appreciate you saying that now uh for
those on the radio you're you're wearing
a dallas hat but the it's it's it's
upside down
yeah it is upside down uh true brand
it's actually one of my teammates uh ben
danucci's brand um so he took the took
the dials took the ds flipped him upside
down and he's doing doing pretty well
with it okay i'm just wondering if it's
there any um i guess
message that's being sent or anything
like that it's just turning you upside
down
yeah you'd have to ask uh ben danucci
yeah it's like a kyler murray situation
should we read into this i don't know do
you see how we reach everybody we
shouldn't read into this
shut that down chris immediately just
shut it down sir shut it down um how how
often have you been thinking about the
way the season ended uh dak how often do
you think about it yeah i mean uh
non-stop honestly multiple times a day
um really yeah i mean it was tough uh it
was tough i mean just
expecting to go so much further to to
have your season um be a lot more than
it was and then just for for it to end
so sudden and especially in the way that
it did uh yeah it's a tough one to
swallow there's certain moments in games
and things that i think will stick with
players or people for a long time in
their career and i think this this game
was one of them no kidding for your
career yeah i mean i just i mean one
this was a team that was
i mean we had everything right i mean it
was we we thought we were headed in the
right direction to do everything that we
needed to do uh to go to go get a win
and um we didn't and the way as i said
the way that it ended i was just one of
those to stick to you those moments that
um an opportunity that you you'll think
about for a long time that did you let
it pass so
so what in particular do you think of
about the ending that you're like okay i
wish i'd what slid sooner or something
like that or or how do you play it back
in your in your mind yeah i mean when i
say this i mean i think i'm more so just
saying the whole the whole season the
fact that the season ended more than
than that last play but yeah the last
play i mean yeah
in retrograde i can say i should have
went down a second earlier but in my
timing and everything um i thought it
was right but you have to um
you have to prepare for human error in
that sense of whether the ball to be
moved or whether two guys running at
each other and um i'll do that now
obviously mm-hmm so yeah
because i'm bringing it up yes you know
yeah because it it you know um and as
you pointed out like everything seemed
to be set up because you know um it it
feels like a million years ago i mean
brady's already retired
and uh but the season opener that night
in tampa and you know everyone's
wondering how you were gonna look
and you came out you threw 400 yards and
the whole thing in and and right away i
thought okay
um i'm not concerned about your leg did
you at all or was that the end of it
that was the end of last year paige
turned week one or there was nothing to
go on that one yeah no that was that was
for sure the end of it i mean obviously
just um so much rehab and everything
that you put in to make sure that you
get back healthy uh for training camp
and then i was able to do that and then
i had the shoulder deal the lat happened
in training camp so then missing more
time uh that just was trying to get to
the season get to the season healthy and
get going and then when i was able to do
that in the first game that was the test
and that was as you say burying the
injury that was okay this is behind me i
went out there i performed the way that
i planned to the way that i expect it to
all the hard work everything that i've
put into this uh is gonna pay off and
then yeah bury the injury and move
forward but then the one that you
suffered in new england that did in fact
set you for a game did that linger
longer than what was uh let on i mean
obviously went on for a couple of weeks
uh going on to that bye week i was able
to rest it then miss the next week out
in minnesota um but i wouldn't say that
it lingered as long as as people
gave me the excuse of it um i
went went through a period in the time
right there in the season just didn't
play my best ball and people tried to
say it was the calf and um the cav got
better i did everything that i needed to
do for it to heal dak prescott here on
the rich eisen show what do you make of
the super bowl matchup what do you think
oh it's it's an exciting one i mean
obviously the uh the bills who come i
almost want to say coming out of nowhere
but uh that wouldn't be fair to say if
they've had a solid season all year long
and then the rams who have invested so
much into this team and right um yeah
it'll be great i mean joe burrows he's
hot uh
um also up for comeback player of the
year um credit to him and just
everything that he's done just his game
and then a guy like matt stafford who's
been through it all and finally getting
his opportunity and i'm excited for the
matchup well i remember you came into
the league and the manner in which you
came in the league and not being
expected at all to do what you did and
how well you performed in your first
year seeing burrow do what he's doing
what is the challenge like what do you
think he's been dealing with that he has
um aced
in a way that you were able to show
everybody that you you could
take on that challenge the way you did
yeah just the speed of the game i mean i
think that's everybody when you wonder
about a rookie quarterback or a young
quarterback coming into the nfl and
william's success is can he do it at the
speed of the game uh and joe's showing
that i mean just from the way he
finished at lsu just to come in the
rookie years have him before getting
hurt to to now uh leading his team to
the super bowl he plays at the game he
slows the game down to his pace and i
think that's what you have to do as a
quarterback is make people play to to
your level uh and he's been doing that
and he's been he's been on fire he's
been pretty impressive right so um
you've played in this building you beat
the chargers in this building um it's a
i mean walking into sofi it's for as a
fan it's like looking into vr goggles i
mean what is it like to for these guys
to be playing in this building it's
great it was my second favorite place uh
only behind att and i just think it's uh
yeah i think it's beautiful i love the
the wrap around um
scoreboard or whatever you say i like
the fact that it's open but it's got the
top on it
uh yeah it's it's great okay is that why
you're saying that because it was kind
of a home game for you too down here
saying that as well a little bit i mean
yeah not many places that the cowboys
don't go that you can't somewhat say
it's a home game
i mean the number of cowboy fans that
were in the building that day he was off
the charts it was fun it is like that is
there an issue with playing at home it
seems like you guys
play crisper on the road is there
something to that at all you're looking
at me like i'm crazy yeah a little bit
thinking and thinking it's all right
yeah
i mean like it it does seem like when
you guys are on the road that you're
it's a much crisper game that uh i don't
i don't know if it's the building or
anything like that or
not yeah i mean yeah no nothing i can't
i can't give you any correlation i'm
sure you're getting a great night's
sleep on your sleep number bet at home
i'm sure exactly
you know
exactly right when you sleep in that
sleep number bed before the home games
you know it's uh what's your what's your
sleep number my sleep numbers are 60.
you know what doc i knew i liked you are
you the same yes
there you go i am
i am yes it's perfect it's just it's
just right just right yeah just your
enough gift but absolutely right yeah
yeah my wife says 70.
just the 10 numbers apart but it's the
world of difference you have the split
in the bin
what do you what do you mean the the bed
that splits i mean you get over there at
70. obviously right if it
makes sense
no it's there's there's no like actual
split in the bed um thank god um but no
like yeah i've got the
the whole thing going on we've got to
get the one with the split so y'all can
you know raise the raise the top up okay
you can you know it's been a while since
i've talked sleep number on this program
and i'm not just saying that it's a
passive aggressive thing to the folks
who are actually sitting here with you
but uh if there's any advent that i need
to know uh it'll be fantastic i know
some people we can
clearly i think they're sitting right
over there but 60 yeah that i this is
amazing all right we're simpatico when
it comes to that uh dak prescott here on
the rich eisen show so what do you make
of um
jerry jones
by the way that's a great way to start
the sentence uh what do you make of
jerry jones saying um that dan quinn is
head coaching material
and did you hear that i didn't say that
no you did that dan quinn coming back
he's a he's a head coaching material and
sean payton was that once back in the
day and jason garrett was once that back
in the day and dan quinn's like that and
when brought up to him like hey you know
what a what do you think your current
head coach thinks about that he's like
well mike is my head coach he's my guy
but uh he knows that someday he won't be
the head coach of the dallas cowboys
anymore what do you make of something
like that yeah i mean i think that's uh
that's obvious i mean obviously coach
won't be coaching uh coaching us for
forever but uh they
coach mccarthy has done a great job just
with the culture of this team so um what
has he done like what's been different
on that front yeah i mean just the
culture just just our messaging um just
the way it's just our brotherhood in our
locker room um i've never been a part of
a team where there was
on offense and defense it was the same
you you would have thought a defensive
end was uh was in the same position
group is a receiver just from how close
in the camaraderie camaraderie of the
group and i credit coach for
um just investing so much into that and
just in the timing and the planning and
everything that we do in our scheduling
to make sure that that we're as
close-knit of a team as we need to be
and in the same sense the coaches are
that as well so i say that is coach
mccarthy knows exactly the kind of coach
dan quinn is uh we all do as players and
even us on offense we know his impact we
know how great of a leader as he is that
he is and i mean he's a coach that took
his team to a super bowl so i mean i
think it's a no-brainer in that he's a
head coach material um but right now
obviously we're all following mccarthy
yeah i know and and i've heard though
that that quinn and mccarthy are like
actually really tight like that they're
you know for sure that and i know you
again for the radio audience you're
looking at me like i'm a little crazy
but from the outside it's like you know
quinn's here he was looking for another
job he's coming back mccarthy the season
didn't end the way it is and jerry's
saying stuff like this that they're that
they might actually be thinking the
knives are out for each other but i've
been told it's the exact opposite
between the two of them yeah it's the i
would say the exact opposite um just
those are two men that have a lot of
respect for one another they take a lot
of pride in their job and they have a
great working relationship so i can
guarantee you that their their ears
aren't anywhere outside of the building
or what's on uh what's most important
well your strike me is also a positive
guy though jack you know so again you
strike me as a positive guy yeah but i
mean i'm gonna make sure that that we're
not uh you know as you said the knives
that are now between our head coaching
our dc that
that that's so false okay so false okay
yeah um and so what pisses you off what
actually pisses you off people cutting
you off in traffic i mean like i'm just
throwing open anything like literally
because you're he's a positive guy and
i'm a very positive guy too and i know
i'm asking you now there's some things
that piss like like what is that what is
it
um eagles fans
i wouldn't say i wouldn't go there
something that pisses me off yeah
anything the other day or anything
happens or what
what upsets you
you know that's a great question i think
it depends on my mood um you know just
uh you know how um
how maybe agitated i am or less agitated
but i think a good one just uh what is
it it's uh
almost just just as you said people
assuming people talking and assuming
things assuming they know
the the locker room or that relationship
or assuming they know me
uh i'd say assuming yeah because you
know what you're doing you assume right
it makes it makes uh you know well
actually you have do you have the uh the
uh michael irvin drop that he used the
other day michael michael well i'm gonna
play off it uh that michael said this
about the dallas cowboys practicing and
the last la super bowl here and he had
the best practice ever and this is after
that practice he knew what they were
going to do to the the buffalo bills hit
it we gonna spank that ass out of you
and me
that's it there you go yeah right there
yeah that's our new favorite drop on the
show and again i'm a host on live
television with michael irvin and
sometimes what's out of his mouth i'm
like i have no idea what i'm gonna
handle this sort of thing so i just kind
of go with the flow but it doesn't piss
me off slow drivers piss me off slow
drivers piss me are you when when
somebody drop again dak prescott you're
driving somebody slow do you look at the
driver that's slow just so you could get
a seat what they look like
i do yeah yeah yeah yeah you definitely
just want to get inside okay so you do
that so we're okay so we got our sleep
number settings the same that's the same
um i don't know what else might be the
possibly the same what do you think
apple on pizza uh pineapple okay that
pisses me off that's out too uh oh gosh
how about this
um uh um
when you fumble through the end zone the
ball goes back to the defense um that's
uh what do you think if you have you
have you ever fumbled through the end
zone no okay uh yeah knuckle would not
have i know that i mean i thought yeah
i'm sorry tj
that pisses me off so bad because i'd
like let's just what do you think you
should just go right back to where he
found it here we go no but it should be
a reverse touch back
you get it it's down in distance uh same
down and distance but from the 20-yard
line
reverse touchback so it's first and goal
from the eight right you're going in
you're trying you're trying dak prescott
you were trying to score
because that's what you do as a dallas
cowboys quarterback you're expected to
score you're expected to win you go for
the you leap for the end zone ball comes
out or what have you and it goes through
the end zone defense that you have just
beaten up for say 10 plays right they
don't get rewarded yeah what's up with
that so you get the ball back on your
own 20 yard line what do you think about
that one i like that very good yeah do
you think the overtime rules should
change
yeah i think it has to in the sense i
mean i think it's i think it's a
an okay rule i mean i'm a big uh
tradition guy right it's been what it is
we don't have to be the same as college
right nfl's nfl colleges college it's a
team game trust your defense to make a
play but
um after you know after not seeing josh
allen get the ball in his hand half
years ago when holmes didn't get the
ball in his hand
i think it's tough i think you you've
got to give the offense a chance
regardless how about this one here's my
here's our fix
um that the opening coin toss of the
game if you win it and you elect to
start on offense you start in the first
quarter and you start in overtime if it
goes
and if you defer then you get it
obviously after half time which so many
teams want to do these days uh but you
then give the ball to the team your
opponent to start the game but you also
so you know in advance who's got the
ball first it's not a coin flip and then
you play a full quarter yeah
and you play so you play you play the
quarter out regardless yeah that's what
you do
i like that that's not that means you're
gonna get the ball because if you say to
somebody hey
you you're going to get to touch it
second right you're not going to want to
start overtime with the ball yourself
right you're going to want to know if
you've got to go score a touchdown
what if the quarter's not over i mean i
can get two possessions regardless right
now that's a strategy yeah that's what
i'm saying let's go
we fixed it yeah you want to talk about
it here you go you go run tell that
you've got power in the league um so
sleep number or tell me more about what
you're doing with them yeah i mean i've
been a partner sleep number for for
five going on five years now and some
great sleep for fun yeah so amazing
sleep for five years obviously
calculating and keeping up my
information so it's proven quality sleep
but not only that just taking the next
step and trying to find my competitive
edge within the sleep and
great people at sleep number have given
me a resource and dr peter polos who um
from everything of your heart rate
maybe you're wondering why you're waking
up in and out of sleep can be a resource
to help me um so now they've helped me
with that giving me that competitive
edge uh and just obviously just the
recovery the bed has has been great for
me just after going through the injury
and going through the off-season and um
not being able to go and see numbers and
stats but but going and getting my
workout in and getting my um rehab in
and filling the improvement and filling
the recovery time and time again uh yeah
i'm blessed to be a partner with sleep
number and they take uh they should take
a lot of pride in my success well uh
congratulations on your success uh so
just to wrap up don't assume right don't
assume that's that's exactly don't
assume around you yep um and because
everything's copacetic right
everything's good in dallas you're going
back in there and you'll be in the super
bowl next year yeah right there you go
right yeah okay for sure there you go so
uh tweet that out uh at dac right back
predict super bowl world championships
there you go yeah you still have like
the underscore on instagram though right
don't you no i think i'm just at where
y'all on instagram yeah on instagram
i've got to understand i like the
underscore what do you mean no why not i
don't know you don't have it you're just
average you know i just i'm at rich
eisen because i would never want
somebody first of all i don't have to
say like a name like dak where you could
just go by your first name and people
know what you're talking about but i
mean i wouldn't want some other
dakota or dak out there going by dak you
know that's what i was just saying get
ready yeah i think i checked it out it's
definitely not a dakota or somebody like
that that's what it says just who's
who's running around with your your
handle yeah i've got to go i don't know
well
let's get on that person
first if at dak removes all of the
dallas cowboys from that person's
instagram page and they'll assume it's
you
yeah that's a problem that's true you
said don't forget the underscore just
confirming though you do follow the
cowboys on instagram i do follow the
couch okay you haven't no one else got
it okay that's it and all of your
cowboys photographs are on
they will stay there very good good good
it's good to hear run tell that
dak on twitter at dak underscore for dak
on instagram see that's a mouthful sorry
all right
it's okay
all's good all's good thanks for coming
on dak always appreciate it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here